first since Elbert maiden the sixth of  his career inbound to a break Bechet  shoot three count the foul  patience by Ricky Rubio the same play we  saw Carmelo Anthony is scored ten here  on the quarters Dillard comes that Rubio  into the land he goes into the air into  the body of Ames and a blocking foul on  Baynes Dame going downhill means has  fouled out Terry Stotts clears it out  for Damian no screen and he lets him go  one-on-one vane slides over will be on  the drive gets a switch and Braves got  it young his head down fine Rubio to his  leg what's up you guys this Taylor  Brooks with bleacher report make sure  that you subscribe for some more video  content